who possible astronauts body Devils
minotaurs pirates okay let's Frank this
[Applause]
[Music]
yes indeed dumb with series six which to
eat which means I need to rank it now
normally this would have fallen not on a
Wednesday but rather on a day that I was
doing other Doctor Who stuff except I'm
running the reviews for the new episodes
airing and it just made more sense to
stick it here so I have finished Doctor
Who series six my rewatch that means I
need to rank the whole thing now because
I count two partners as one stories that
means that we have eleven of these to
rank starting at the bottom working our
way up and number eleven is wedding of
River Song
it's a rough thing when at least to my
estimation the worst episode of the
series is the last one that was the last
taste left in the mouth if you'd asked
me to rank these back when it first
aired I probably would have not put this
one at the very bottom but the thing is
knowing some of the stuff that it sets
up or that stuff that it sets up that it
fails to deliver decently on in the end
of this sort of takes the idea of oh I'm
excited to see what happens next out of
it and once that's gone there isn't a
lot to recommend this episode it's a
jumble of too many dang ideas there's a
handful of decent scenes usually based
around good character interactions but
there's other parts where the tonal
shifts are just an absolute mess and
just trying to deal with the plot knots
that the series has tied itself into it
just doesn't quite work moving up to
number 10 we need to let's kill Hitler
boy we're on a roll the showrunner of
the time with the bottom two episodes of
the series hmm that's rough let's kill
Hitler has a lot of the same problems
that wedding of River Song does the
reason I put it a little bit higher is
because at least for my taste the issues
that I have with it run a little bit
deeper in wedding of River Song and
there are a few more bright spots in
let's kill Hitler again most of the good
parts based around character
interactions but also some of the plot
bits if you can deal with what a tonal
shift this was from the episode that
immediately preceded it I guess I
they could get away with it because
there was sort of a hiatus in between
but boy it really is jarring if you're
just revisiting this stuff but you know
it is there is a light fun element to it
that fits it a bit more taken as a thing
unto itself then whatever the heck the
vibe of wetting the river song was again
it's a bit of a mess it's just slightly
less of a mess than whatever sewing at
least by my estimation number nine
closing time I'm a mild defender of this
episode but not really the whole episode
only if certain elements of it I do
actually think that the use of the
Cybermen and this is pretty good and
pretty solid I think that it's
interesting I think the way that they
are defeated is legitimate I kind of
like the stuff with storm again that
like the use of the cyber mess I thought
that was neat but I do not care for the
humour in this one at all it is it's
just it just makes me cringe and I know
cringe is really kind of become an
overused word especially when it comes
to YouTube criticism but like there's no
other word for it it's that kind of
humor it's just ugh
awkward just frustrating embarrassing
really uncomfortable misunderstandings
that go on for way too long
it just doesn't click which is
frustrating because I actually thought
the humour worked pretty well in the
larger but bringing Craig back for a
second go they just could not recapture
it number eight night terrors this one
is fine overall like we got we've gotten
through the ones that I think have real
legitimate issues and at this point
where we're at ones that I'm like fine
and that's kind of where I am at night
terrors I know some people actually
really like this one and wow I don't
think it's awful the sort of parenting
metaphor that it's that's being done
with it it's just for someone who's like
a really easy mark for parental stories
cuz I have a kid and especially these
days that stuff hits me a lot harder
than it used to back when this thing
aired in the first place but you like at
this point it just didn't connect with
me and it should've I should have been
an easy mark for that and it still
didn't quite get me so I feel like
something is a little bit off
that also it didn't help that I don't
find the dolls creepy just because they
don't find dolls inherently creepy so
that part was lost on me as well
again it's fine it just doesn't really
have a lot of highlights at least not
for me
number seven curse of the black spot
this one I probably have higher than
most people will put it because I'm a
sucker for pirates I mean that's pretty
much it I like the feel and the vibe and
the swashbuckling adventure and I love
Amy I love how excited she is to put on
a pirate outfit and wave a sword around
and I actually don't even mind the
explanation on this one as much as it is
a oh it's this ancient folklore creature
no it's alien as much as it is that and
I don't love that pattern in Doctor Who
I know it doesn't bug me as much this
time again maybe I'm giving it a pass
because it's pirates but look we've all
got our soft spots pirates is one of
mine I liked it
number six the rebel flesh and the
almost people I really at this point
getting into the the top half of this a
lot of these I feel like our under
appreciated episodes and at this point
we are dealing with I think legitimately
good stuff the bottom end of this series
was rough but from here on out it's
pretty dang solid stuff and I really do
like this two-parter it's got its little
hiccups along the way especially goblin
we have to deal with that child actor in
the second part that's that's rough
stuff but the emotions still ring true
for a lot of it I find the interaction
the way it plays out to be interesting
to be well thought out to not go as
obvious as you would have expected this
sort of thing to go I thought the stuff
done with the doctor and the gang or
doctor were interesting and and fun to
watch and really set a lot not only
about the relationship that Amy
especially has with the doctor but how
the doctor kind of pushes her to realize
her own issues and and things and I
really did enjoy that plus the ending
and how it sets up what's to come boy
that was a kick in the teeth but in the
best way number five The Impossible
Astronaut and the day of the moon so
there's a lot of like but first of all I
like this
I just do I love them visually and I
love them as a concept because I will
always find them scarier than the
weeping angels even though they have
effectively the same gimmick you are in
the least amount of danger while you are
looking at them the mecan't but the
mechanics of it are just different
enough that that's why I find them scary
because the idea of something getting in
your head
to change your memory so that you cannot
trust your own mind I find that much
scarier than the more visceral scare of
the weeping angels because look mental
degradation is something that scares me
like a philosophical existential level
that scares the crap out of me so having
a creature that ties into that yeah
that's gonna hit me a bit harder than
then moving statues are going to and
beyond that I love the resolution that
there's something really triumphant
about the doctor playing that clip you
know one small step for man you should
kill us all on sight oh that is such a
triumphant moment when you realize what
it is he's doing oh it's so good the
only reason this two-parter isn't higher
again if I was doing this Rangi back
when the thing first aired it might have
been the only reason I don't put it
higher is because I feel like some of
the things that sets up the payoffs
aren't great particularly when it comes
to the Impossible Astronaut itself but
self-contained as a two-parter
I really do dig this thing number four
the god complex
uh I love the setting creepy hotel I
like the sort of labyrinthine nature of
the hotel being home to a Minotaur
labyrinthine hotel labyrinth Minotaur
duh but I really find it wonderfully
creepy the whole idea of all these doors
and it's something it's something you
fear more than anything else and then it
turns that fear around into something
that it's gonna take that away from you
so you don't fear anymore so now you
praise it now you worship it and it
beads on that it's it's this twisting of
faith it's this twisting of psychology
of mental state again that I think is is
nicely unnerving and the way that it
gets into the heads of the various
characters the way that's played out the
way keeps showing Rory the exit cuz it's
got enough they can't get anything from
him
the idea that Amy's greatest fear is
just waiting forever for the doctor and
him not showing up ah
the this episode understands these
characters and the guest characters who
are also great but it understands these
characters so well it's just what
number three a good man goes to war
don't worry Moffat I did I did save you
a spot in the top three for something
that you wrote after you occupied the
bottom for this season otherwise good
man goes to war is just energizing
there's something really thrilling about
them going for a me and I will always
love the doctor just Amelia pond get
your coat then the lights go down like
all he is so on top of this I love it I
love the introduction of vastra and
Jenny and Strax and dorium I have fun
with the triumph of what they are able
to accomplish and then it all comes
crashing down when the baby is a flesh
avatar and Amy sells that horror of
realizing she has lost her child she
sells that really well the desperation
screaming for Rory and her anger at the
doctor and River trying to figure out
what is going on and then but like the
thing at the end realizing who river is
and the music that is played for that oh
wow this is a wonderful emotional
rollercoaster of an episode up then down
then up again
aha I live for this sort of stuff
number two the girl who waited it's hard
for me to fully explain why I'm putting
this one above good man goes to war but
it's just such a wonderful exploration
of Amy as a character and the potential
of what she can be for good and ill and
Karen Gillan freaking nails it she
brings so much to both parts both young
Amy and old Amy and and Rory also it's
amazing work the the struggle that he
has having to leave her behind and the
doctor is a that doctors a dick
forcing Rory to be the one to have to
make that choice oh that was a coward
move
to put that in Rory's hands oh it's so
emotionally fraught this episode the
anger the bitterness the hope the
failure this really does encapsulate so
much of what I love about Karen Gillan's
performance and of a me as a character
like I've mentioned this repeatedly
I've always liked Amy but doing this
revisit has really realized how much I
love Amy she is a really good character
well thought out and a lot more fleshed
out thanks to Karen Gillan's performance
she brings a lot more than what's on the
page and what's on the page is already
pretty good but she brings such a
fully-formed character and this is such
a wonderful showpiece for her much in
the way that Amy's choice was as well
which I also ranked to really high when
I did series 5 I guess I just really
loved Amy and finally taking the number
one spot the doctor's wife because it is
just the right mix of sentimental and
exciting and funny and touching and has
its little unnerving moments you know
with the voice that Michael Sheen brings
to house which is nicely creepy and some
of the ways he toys with Amy and Rory
the doctor getting to talk this way to
the TARDIS for the first time their
interactions their banter their and just
the ways in which he gets to chew her
out she gets to chew him out right back
what does it say on the door it says
pulled open what do you do I push I love
the two of them fighting like this
bitter old married couple but the love
is still there it's so great like this
whole idea of putting the TARDIS into a
body that should have been stupid and
cheesy and tacky and grating but it's
not it's
freaking perfect Thank You Neil Gaiman's
for giving me what I feel is the best
episode of series 6 that's my ranking
what's yours
whatever your thoughts are on either my
ranking or if you want to share what
yours would be drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it you
can help me out by liking it subscribing
if you haven't already leaving the
comments also helps me along plus I have
a patreon if you want to support what I
do and help me continue to grow it is
greatly appreciated plus there's links
to other stuff down below besides just
that I've got an Instagram now for the
council of geeks but if you don't want
to do any of that you don't have to
because end of the day you're the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]